our exchange community has grown since 1792 to
more than 1,350 members more than 650 member
firms more than 2,500 offices more than 64,000
people handling the orders that funnel into this
central market where financial institutions
direct a great volume of transactions to buy
and sell listed securities each minute the
institutional investor has an average of
twelve thousand dollars of new money to invest
twelve thousand dollars a minute there are
good many ways that institutional investors
are taking best advantage of this versatile
market created by broad public participation
and because most of your orders are executed
in the regular auction market but to take
a closer look at it starting with a quick
rundown on the men who transact your everyday
business on the floor or who calls for the
firm's floor broker by flashing his number the
broker goes to his clerk and picks up the order
he goes to the post gets the quote and joins the
crowd as other brokers bid or offer with him he
states his offer in a loud clear voice the sale is
made and recorded there are no written contracts
the brokers word is enough news of the sale is
spent to the ticker then word is sent to your
member book each specialist handles an average of
11 stocks with market activity constantly flowing
around him the specialist performs the first of
his two important functions acting as a brokers
broker when your floor broker cannot immediately
complete an order and an acceptable price he can
entrust the order to the specialist who then
becomes a member of your market team obligated
to get you the best price he can the order is
then entered in this confidential book here's
the way it works because he knows his issues
because he knows the market the specialist is
able to perform his second job helping to keep
that market fair and orderly though stock prices
rise or fall because of supplier demand it is the
specialists function to keep the spread between
bids and offers and price variations between sales
as narrow as circumstances will permit as a result
he's usually buying for his own account when the
market is falling or selling when the market is
rising but he may buy or sell only when there
is no public order on his book at that price
but this flexible market is all the way from you
on the floor however let's assume you insist upon
dividing your block among three brokers you give
this broker the first part of your order to sell
after the execution is reported to you you give
the second part of the block to another broker
another down and the third
part to still another broker
you'll just become your own worst enemy one broker
completely in your confidence knowing exactly what
you wanted could have been much more efficient but
the real test of a markets efficiency is not how
it operates when things are going well but how
it functions when something unexpected happens
in times of crisis the exchange is open
every minute of every business day its
member firms are available to customize
their lines are open to the floor the
specialists are at their posts ready to team
up with your broker ready to do their part in
meeting the exchanges objective to keep
the market orderly the emergency passes
the auction market created by public orders
responsive to your needs man by experts it is
central flexible liquid each day this market
handles more than 125 million dollars in buy
and sell orders it's special procedures
its experienced market teams provide you
with all the techniques all the services
to carry out your investment decisions